was a big night for lizzo at last
night's mtv video music awards winning
video for good after performing her
recently released track to be loved
yes and lizzo came to play on the red
carpet in the show-stopping voluminous
gown and her most gothic look today
carlito oh what did you think of this
one okay so i saw this immediately and i
was like this is like high fashion on
this carpet right now not a lot of
people bring that sort of high fashion
like the vmas are the the carpet where
you kind of show off the books that
people are supposed to be talking about
right and it wasn't right i didn't get
that from a whole lot of people i got
that from a few but not a whole lot of
people but lizzo came in
she was like everyone's going to be
talking about this one you know also
yeah people could definitely talk about
it it made me think of do you remember
when she um
showed that video of her like audition
for the little mermaid where she wanted
to be ursula singing like poor
unfortunate souls
this is like this is like the real life
uh red carpet black carpet version of
that look good i like it it's giving
it's giving adam's family wednesday but
maybe a tuesday i don't know okay i'm
not loving the lunk i'm not loving this
but she could hide a lot of things in
there like i would bring my dog right i
would bring my purse
i don't know maybe snacks um just saying
lighting like i would just
if you only had like if you only had a
plus two to the vmas but you needed to
bring a plus three and four also a good
way to bring more family with you to the
show boom
i think it's very i think it's cool it's
a really cool look all right and later
in the evening lizzo clapped back at her
body shamers after comedian aries spears
recently made some harsh comments about
her appearance
yeah during a recent interview with art
of dialogue aries took jabs at liz's
weight and called out the women who
support her and are inspired by her
confidence
she's got a very pretty face
but she keeps showing her body off
like come on man
come on yo
i'm sorry listen i ain't the most in
shape
in the world but i still you know when
you funny and you got swagger and
confidence
and and you decent looking i think i'm
at least handsome
you get
but a woman that's built like a plate of
mashed potatoes is in trouble you know
what kills me about women
is is the hypocrisy and the
contradiction yes queen slay queen your
ass queen slay yeah girl your confidence
diabetes
heart heart problems
heart disease cholesterol
you all claim womanhood and about
sisterhood and support for your sister
you know when it come to that
ridiculous
but if you really gave a
why wouldn't you go black girl we love
you we love your confidence boo boo but
this ain't it this ain't it
okay and who gives an f about you yeah
clearly
um and moving on um now her acceptance
speech last night lizzo directly
addressed those who make comments about
her appearance in the most lizzo fashion
way possible
i want to say thank you so much for
supporting me and loving on me
and now
that got something to say about me in
the press
you know what i'm not gonna say nothing
they'd be like lizzie why don't you clap
back why don't you clap back cause i'm
winning
[Applause]
[Music]
that is the most liberal reaction like
that is the most lizzo i love that all
right however eliza wasn't specifically
calling it aries spears explaining on
twitter uh let me make one thing very
clear i wasn't addressing anybody in my
speech last night i was addressing
everybody everybody everyone
yes yeah
this is like
yeah you know my feeling is
you know you don't have to like
everything that everyone is doing you
don't you know it's your you know right
to have but everybody has one life to
live and they have the right to do
whatever they want with it why are you
so bothered and so offended maybe you
should work on yourself and figure it
out why are you so triggered by what
someone else is doing to the point that
you're doing all of this and i get aries
as a comedian and you guys know how i am
with comedians i feel like comedians are
allowed to say whatever they want but as
long as it's actually funny
it wasn't even funny and then just to
sit there and to say oh you know i know
i'm not you know in the best shape but
you know at least i'm funny and i might
be good looking like huh if you're
thinking with that theory lizzo is
talented lizzy can write a song lizzle
can sing and she's charismatic and also
she's more relevant than you boo-boo so
why are we even like why does she bother
you and her confidence you know it's one
thing to be worried about someone's
health you can say something about
someone being extremely skinny and being
worried about their health like are you
okay you know that is a concern is
always okay
but
shaming someone's body and acting like
they're not healthy and making all these
comments it's like
what does that have to do with you she
can be confident in her skin as long as
people aren't trying to kill themselves
like they're people who commit suicide
every single day based off this type of
opinion
people shaming people let people enjoy
their lives there's it's already hard as
it is to have to listen to aries
freaking spears like bye boo
movie fan here says who is this bloke
you know people really love uh lizzo for
a lot of things her music her body
positivity is one of the things that
people really love her for
and like that to me the way that she
handles it and the way that she's out
there doing her thing um
being like an inspiration for people
kind of yeah
the sort of reaction that
you know an aries spears is giving like
that
it just kind of like disappears do you
know what i mean like someone could come
out and say some of that you know
you're showing us
how much your opinion doesn't matter
because this person is on top of the
world and kind of leading the charge for
a a better way to um talk about how you
are who you are and a better a better
way to uh be an influence for people so
as little yeah all right yeah like what
would aries prefer her to like be
ashamed and like hide her body and have
to live in a world like why why yeah let
her be confident like why does it bother
you so much why don't you get better
jokes
anyway let's move on